thank you heidi i
am i am definitely a stanford brat um
when i finally um got married in 1998
and danielle and i decided to move to
san francisco my mother was in tears
she's like oh my god you're leaving us
like you're moving all the way to san
francisco i'm like mom i'm finally
leaving the zip code for the first time
in my life um i'd also like to just
acknowledge right from the get-go
uh my father professor haresh shah who
got his graduate degree and his
doctorate here at stanford and then came
back to teach as a young professor
which is why i grew up on the stanford
campus and my father's
life work as a pioneering researcher in
the field of earthquake risk assessment
was not only the inspiration for this
business but as a catalyst and without
his
his support rms never would have been
born let alone thrived
over the years now as a catastrophe
modeler
i had to check out this building before
agreeing to come and give a presentation
so we ran this uh this building through
our model and
we looked it up in our database and it's
something we call a class reconstruction
which is quite good
recent construction 125 000 square feet
four stories in height i hope we've got
that right in our database
uh we then looked at its uh local hazard
environment properties it's on soft rock
to stiff soil
that's pretty good a low potential for
liquefaction which is soil failure
due to the water content in the soil and
very low landslide potential we're on
pretty firm
flat and we're unfortunately about 4.3
miles from the san andreas fault
now when we crank this through our
stochastic models
we are estimating that there is a 90
there's there's 90 percent chance over
the next 50 years that the damage to
this building does not exceed
14 now i know that would be cold comfort
of an earthquake strikes
during this presentation but this is a
pretty well-built well-situated
property and according to the rms models
uh you're in good shape and
we should be fine so um this photo
was taken back in 1989
of uh weyman dong my co-founder who was
an associate professor
at stanford and myself we look much
younger and better
24 25 years ago and uh that's
a a copy of uh what we call iris version
one which we shipped on a five and a
quarter inch floppy diskette
the as part of i guess being a faculty
brat we worked on the business plan
here at stanford um the whole thing was
a bit of an accident because
i took a class i was a i was a an
engineering
uh student doing my master's work in the
engine what that was then called the
engineering
management program and the business
school i think in a a nod to
multiculturalism
uh set up a program that i think they
called uh entrepreneurship in high
technology
and the gsb welcomed a few of us a few
of us scruffy engineering
grad students into their class to kind
of foster some
cross-functional collaboration and some
some innovation in order to pass the
damn class
we had to write a business plan for a
high technology startup
so i and a few of my friends to pass the
class i
developed the business plan for what
became risk management software at the
time now risk management solutions
and it was a very productive use of
school time and
various professors during that master's
year were very kind in giving me time
to continue to sharpen the business plan
uh during that final masters year
at stanford now our story over time is
we
started uh with offering a single model
for
three cities in california to quantify
earthquake risk and over the years we
followed a pretty
uh straightforward strategic playbook um
extending the geography of what we model
from california to the united states to
japan etc
expanding the number of perils we model
from earthquake hazards to a range of
climactic hazards to terrorism hazards
the disease pandemics
and being able to modern more and more
classes of physical and financial
exposure
and this has been our journey over the
years what i'd like to do in this talk
is not
uh bore you too much with the background
of rms give you a bit of context about
the business
uh tell you some stories about some of
the
shenanigans and and challenges that we
encountered along the way
and then wrap up with a few comments
about
what i may have learned or be learning
about this and then try to leave some
time at the end for questions
now one mark of progress in the business
is that our models have gotten a lot
more
sophisticated over the years when we
started version one again
three cities in california earthquake
risk only
we shipped on 17 five and a quarter inch
floppy diskettes
our most recent release in 2013
um global models multiple perils if we
shipped on five and a quarter inch
floppies would be about
500 000 of these five and a quarter inch
floppies probably cargo container load
uh full of media to drop on premise at a
client's side which is one of the
reasons we're now moving to the cloud
but i guess that's that's progress of
sort so we now have a pretty wide range
of models
uh for most geographies around the world
we model earthquake risk we model
hurricane risk we model cyclone risk
typhoon risk flood risk fire risk winter
storms tornado hail
we model terrorism risk 28 different
attack modes from improvised explosive
devices to chemical nuclear biological
and radiological devices
we model a range of pandemic diseases
that could cause significant
human casualties and financial impacts
around the world
and we also even have a practice that is
modeling what we call longevity risk
which is trying to assess the potential
for a catastrophic
increase in life expectancy due to uh
things like the biology of aging and
regenerative medicine uh there is a
chance that life expectancy increases in
very unexpected ways and while that's a
good thing for all of us
uh it could be a significant financial
catastrophe for
for some institutions and so that's a
growing practice in the business
and we're even doing some research and
development around things like supply
chain risk
um and for financial contagion um
as well so pretty broad range of apparel
models
uh catastrophe models for a wide range
of geographies for a wide range of uh
uh exposures a couple just factoids
about the business um
we started there were five of us uh
we're now the world's leading
catastrophe modeling firm we have 1
300 employees around the world uh we
have
hundreds of clients this is not a
business that has tens or hundreds of
thousands or millions of
of uh consumers uh pinging our website
this is a business that serves
hundreds of institutional clients around
the world to help them manage their
financial risk to catastrophic events we
have a subscription business model
uh in which we license our analytics and
our
intellectual property with an annual
recurring revenue model while we do do
some consulting work
and just to give you a sense of
individual client revenues range from
about a hundred thousand dollars a year
to license our models and data and
analytics to uh over 10 million
a year is our our largest single client
and our models
are embedded into the fabric of the
insurance reinsurance and special
investors that we serve
helping them to price structure and
underwrite risk assess and manage
capital and exposure to these risks and
develop and implement mitigation
strategies
to reduce the consequences of these
disasters
i thought i'd say a couple of words
about what the hell a catastrophe model
is
for those of you who might be wondering
this is not a
closed form mathematical model this is
not a single analytic
expressed with n parameters it is a
composite model
which is a attempt to characterize using
stochastic techniques the underlying
characteristics of earthquake occurrence
in this case
the frequency of events where they occur
what the local consequences are of those
events saying ground shaking at this
site what the exposure is to this
individual building
to that ground shaking how that
translates into things like physical
damage
to the property and potential for human
harm for occupants in the building
through to the financial consequences of
uh
of those damages so that uh our
financial services clients can assess
the risk that's what we mean by a
catastrophe model this is just an
illustration
of an earthquake model but the
architecture is similar
for the climactic hazard models for the
terrorism models uh the
the pandemic models and so on there's
lots of ways that these models
can be expressed here's a couple of
expressions of our terrorism model
you can express these the the model
output as a scenario
so you can go into the stochastic model
and pluck out an event
such as a five-ton truck bomb attack um
in times square in new york city we
model the bomb blasts the effects of
canyon
channeling pressure waves through the
urban environment it could assess the
footprint of damage from an individual
scenario in this case a truck bomb
attack you can also express this as a
risk map which is the integration of all
the possible events
that we think might occur so get a kind
of contour of risk throughout say
manhattan but our sort of defining and
signature expression
of risk is something that we call an
exceeding probability curve
which is a way of expressing risk which
is what is the probability
over a given time period that there is
x dollars euros yen pounds what have you
of loss or greater
to an asset or portfolio of assets so
this particular curve you'd read is
saying
there is a one percent chance per year
that this asset has 200 million dollars
of loss
or more from the underlying events that
we're simulating
this asset could be millions of
insurance policies
it could be one large industrial
facility it could be
a large urban environment but this is
the kind of
output that we generate and it's pretty
significant
big compute big data and analytic output
often the input data to these models
runs in the gigabytes
and the output from individual analysis
can run into the terabytes
and in some cases into the petabytes of
information just for one
uh set of simulated outputs so this is
pretty significant
computational uh resources get brought
to bear and i'll talk a bit about
that later as part of the some of the
stories about
rms now just to bring to life briefly uh
before reverting back to the beginning
and walking through
uh some of the things we've experienced
as a business just to illustrate
a typical use case uh for these
catastrophic models now
uh it wasn't that long ago when
hurricane sandy
super storm sandy barreled into the u.s
northeast
one of many really bad outcomes
was that the new york city subway system
mta
was completely submerged and flooded
with
water the economic losses were
extraordinary
to the new york subway system and we
were enlisted
after hurricane sandy to help them
construct
a a parametric hedge
against future flooding losses to the
new york mta
so that they can construct a bond
against that parametric trigger
and and lay off financial risk from
storm church flooding
into investors into the capital markets
and rms got retained
to perform the analysis of the new york
city subway system
to help construct the parameters that
would drive the trigger to the bond
and help them construct the deal and
then support the placement into the
capital markets
this is the kind of financially minded
use case
around an rms catastrophe model that
happens
quite often with our customers and in
this particular case
this is this particular catastrophe bond
was awarded non-traditional deal deal of
the year by bond buyer last year
and it helped the new york mta close its
financial risk gap to future storm surge
events
and this is the kind of thing that we do
and there was a lot of publicity about
this deal
in the wall street journal so that's
just one of many use cases that
i could uh share about how catastrophe
modeling
gets used to inform financial risk
management decisions in the real world
and how we add value to our customers
okay so that's a bit of the background
in some context to
rms as a business i'd like to share with
you um
uh with some of the time we have here
some of the stories
along the way that informed
my own journey as a co-founder and ceo
and shaped the development of this
business over the last 25 years actually
it's a very
wonderful time to be giving this talk
this year 2014
is the 25 year anniversary since we
formally incorporated
and started our business so
start with the the experimentation phase
when we first formed the business
otherwise known as
the start up chaos we were
equipped uh with a bit of money from my
father and a couple of his friends i
guess now the term of art is angel
investing
but the uh the early days of rms were
were pretty seated the pants
the first office that we had was my
apartment
and uh we used to uh uh play some games
with our early customers
who hopefully aren't watching right now
where when we get phone calls
to my apartment that involved any sort
of technical challenge
i would have this system set up where i
would have a phone or i could
have two lines page my co-founder weiman
dong
who was the brains of the operation uh
conference call him
in and patch him into the client to
create the impression that we had a
proper firm that could answer their
questions and there was this kind of
this kind of craziness
another kind of example of the early
chaos and
improvisation was we had an early
prospect
uh uh who wanted to take a look at our
software
they were domiciled in the u.s east
coast and we didn't have enough money
to make the uh the trip over to the east
coast to set up shop and give them a
proper extended workshop and demo
so being very naive we said well tell
you what if you want to take a look at
our software why don't you advance us
some money
so we can fly out to visit you run the
workshop and if you decide to buy the
software
we'll credit it back against the
purchase price there's a lot of
crazy stuff like that at one point we we
basically ran out of money
and one of our early colleagues another
stanford grad
turned up for work and i had to inform
him that we really couldn't
pay him very much anymore because
they're running out of money but he
could move into my apartment free of
charge
in order to uh provide him the ability
to uh still work at the company
the early days were were wonderful for a
lot of reasons uh not the least being
the great team i'd say of the first 25
people i'm going to
call out a couple of my early colleagues
who are here in the audience today
i think about 80 percent of us of the
first 25 people were all stanford
uh grads they were either friends of
mine from the class of 88 or 89
they were friends of friends who also
were stanford grads they were
part of my father's network of grad
students post-docs
research associates so there's a real
kind of stanford
ethos camaraderie and sense of shared
mission
that got us through a lot of those crazy
days we used to pull lots of
all-nighters like every startup does and
we used to have staff meetings
on the big choice of whether we have the
staff meeting the stanford pub
rich remember or 42nd street i don't
know if any of you remember
uh 42nd street which was a great bar in
downtown palo alto
where we used to have some of our staff
meetings
now when we first got started we did
have
a version one uh of our product
this is what it looked like it shipped
on the seventeen five and a quarter
floppy as diskettes
coded in fortran 77 um but we understood
even back then
uh we had the intuition to recognize
that this is really a proof of concept
and what we needed to do in these early
days was experiment
and engage in actual work with real
customers
to really understand what was the
product that we could deliver that would
really
solve concrete use cases and add
concrete business value
so in the early days what we set out to
do was a lot of experimentation rather
than saying
we had our v1 product now we're going to
take it to market
we spent a lot of time essentially even
though we knew very clearly that we were
a software company
a lot of the early engagements were
essentially consulting projects
signing up customer my customer on the
concept that an earthquake risk model
could add value but really engaging with
them the consultative work
to figure out how this really could be
made useful to a specific business
problem
we spent countless hours and days hold
up with our customers
understanding how they did business
understanding their vernacular
what kind of data did they capture how
did they make an underwriting decision
how did an insurance loss control
engineer go into the field
to collect data about a piece of
property to make a recommendation of the
insurance underwriter
how could we deliver a piece of software
that might facilitate that decision
and so on and so forth so it was a
period of great experimentation
to really learn the use cases of our
customers get paid for doing so
in order to get to a place where we
could say that we understood
what the product strategy needed to be
now some of this experimentation
got a bit crazy one of the more wild
experiments
that we did because you get distracted
when you're 23 24 years old
is that we thought how what if we
constructed offered a product
which was an earthquake report that we
could sell to homeowners in palo alto
in order to help them as consumers
assess their risk to earthquake damage
and we got off of this crazy tangent
where we were constructing
consumer brochures gotting buying
mailing lists
mailing out brochures um collecting
information by
fax about homeowners homes running
reports it's like the old days of
e-commerce when you order the sneakers
somebody goes runs out buys a pair of
tennis shoes
and ships it to you you know we would
get the fax in we would type it into our
computer we compile a report and send it
and charge 100 bucks a complete disaster
and certainly something that we learned
the hard way not to build a business to
consumer business
uh around our earthquake risk analytics
but a lot of experimentation is learning
not only what does work uh what doesn't
work
and as we approach the end of this
experimentation phase we learned a lot
of things
uh but one thing that really got us into
a bit of a jam
was that by the early 90s towards the
end of this phase
we probably had about 20 to 23 clients
who had paid us real money to experiment
with them
on how an earthquake risk model for
california could add value
to an insurance or financial services
use case but with 22 clients i think we
had probably 23 or 24
versions of our software and we were a
little bit out of control
and it was a real challenge to balance
that kind of need for experimentation
in the context of actual customer use
cases and actually then reconcile that
with the need to build
a scalable business around a singular
vision of what the product strategy was
and and an actual product development
plan to deliver
that kind of capability so a great deal
of experimentation
some misfires and a bit of a jam
we then got into a phase where it was
really about establishing
uh the business model by by
1993 we were able to raise about 3
million dollars in venture capital
on the basis of some of the early
evidence that we had that customers
would pay us money
for an earthquake risk model and we had
been able to upgrade our digs from a
small office in palo alto
over to one on castro street in uh in
mountain view
but at this point in the uh the journey
i encountered one of the early crucibles
that many young
entrepreneurs encounter and that's
the recognition of one's own
limitations and to have the humility
and the self-awareness to not stand in
the way
of what's needed to build a real
business and grow
we went through the process of raising
venture capital
i came to uh be introduced to my
colleague tom hutton
who's sitting here in the front row and
tom
also a stanford grad uh engineering um
ms and then went on to do his uh his uh
mba
at harvard um was introduced to us
as a potential ceo to
build the next phase of the business as
part of
raising capital and and
really starting to get more systematic
about what it takes to really build a
software business
out of the experimentation phase and i
think one of the things that
was very real learning experience for me
was knowing when it's okay to ask for
help
and to stand aside and let someone come
in to help teach you and over the years
tom became a mentor and taught me pretty
much everything i now know about
business
and helped really systematize from those
early experimental days
the company into a much more scalable
business model
during this phase we not only focused on
course on adding more customers
and adding more employees and building
the business there were two key
challenges that we really focused on one
was
articulating the product strategy
and understanding what is the coherent
value proposition
in and the use cases that we needed to
deliver against to fulfill that value
proposition
and develop a proper product roadmap
and product development plan to kind of
pivot from
lots of experimentation with lots of
customers and lots of
individual wins to something
coherent and scalable in our case we
stepped back
with tom and rich boyle another
colleague who was our first head of
engineering
colleague class of 88 at stanford as
well
we built a proper product roadmap that
recognized it's the category
is an earthquake risk model it's natural
hazard model it's not california
it's global and it's not just insurance
or reinsurance
but it's multiple classes of exposure
articulated that roadmap
and with the investment capital we raise
we're able to then invest
in building against that roadmap another
key challenge that we overcame at this
point is what's the business model
of the business at the time we had
envisioned that we being a software
business would sell our software
i think the price points at the time
were fifteen thousand dollars
twenty-five thousand dollars and we
would charge an annual
uh maintenance fee fifteen twenty
percent twenty-five percent
against that initial sale and that's how
we were going to build the business
during this phase we came to understand
that to build a scalable business
it's not just about the technology or
the product it's the business model
itself what's the business model
that is right for this kind of
technology that can create a sustainable
and durable source
of revenue to fund the growth of the
business
and we re-envision the business not as a
software lice uh
perpetual software sale but as an annual
subscription model
which was a key innovation at the time
which has led to the recurring revenue
business model
that has enabled us to sustain the
growth year after year from
uh to about 300 million dollars in
revenue is what we have today so there
was a lot of work in this phase
raising venture capital articulating a
coherent product strategy
executing it and also being clear about
what kind of business model we needed to
put in place
in order to sustain uh this business
over time
so by the uh by the late uh 1990s
we were feeling uh pretty good we had
grown
from um you know two three million in
revenue over the decade to about 30
million in revenue
factor of 10 x increase in revenues we
were making a bit of money
which is always helpful we had some
pretty good customers
we had a range of models for different
perils and different geographies around
the world
and we even had we were very thrilled
it's a sort of sign of
coming of age we even had an industry
analyst called the tower group
write a industry report about this
nascent market called
catastrophe modeling and we felt like
okay we've established the business we
have real customers
we have a good business model we're
making a bit of money
analysts are talking about cap modeling
as a product
category um 30 million dollar niche
analytics business that's not
so bad a lot of niche analytics business
get to 20 30 40 million dollars
and that's their potential we've grown
by a factor of 10.
and uh we began to uh enter a phase i
refer to in hindsight as
the mature market fallacy um
and this was a very um interesting
learning experience there were a couple
of things going on
um at this phase in the business uh one
is that we began to think of the
business as
starting to mature you know you look
backwards 10x growth that's not bad
30 million in software recurring revenue
uh is pretty good um we looked around
and said you know we've built
models from most of the developed
countries we had an earthquake model
not only for the us but for japan we had
a win you know we had wind models for
europe we had
we had typhoon models for japan we had
earthquake models for latin america
we had penetrated a lot of our uh major
uh target customers and we started to
think about
the business as a maturing specialty
analytics business
that certainly we thought could continue
to grow
but that perhaps the significant
growth story was behind us
at that point we made the decision to
sell the business
to the daily mail in general trust which
i won't get into the details
but it was part of the mindset which was
that we had
invested in this little startup we had
overcome the the
years of startup chaos we had validated
our value proposition we raised venture
capital
we invested in building a coherent
product line we had good
close customers we had a good revenue
was growing but beginning to
growth was beginning to slow and sort of
the thought was
it's the logical time to exit
unfortunately around the same time which
was fueling
this view of the mature market fallacy
sometimes business challenges are
are exogenous to your business for those
of you who
recall this time uh this was the the
dot-com boom was approaching its
crescendo
um in the end of the 1990s it got to the
point where
um around 99 and 2000 um
we started to experience um
this kind of combination of this is a
maturing business
and this tremendous exogenous uh
forces of the dot-com boom um lots of
those lots of us who had joined the
business as kids were getting ready to
move on um
we had to one example is we had to
relocate our office
and at the time uh landlords were
getting uh
warrants and equity in technology
company in silicon valley in return for
office space we couldn't afford that
we went like refugees across the
dumbarton bridge in a wagon train
to newark california we felt like we
weren't at the center
of this transformative thing called the
internet
and and it was a very scary time we had
uh
one year um i can't recall that was 99
or 2
000 i think it was 99 where our turnover
rate approached
40 percent in the company and this is
not four out of 10 people we had
you know close to we had probably around
100 plus people in the business to lose
almost half your company
for all the right reasons tremendous
opportunities we had grown the business
uh there were uh there's a liquidity
event um but it was a very scary time
trying to manage through this process
and we began to think of the business
mature maturing
and we made the decision to sell the
business and many of the startup team
exited lots of hugs and handshakes
but people started to move on and
there's a tremendous amount of turnover
at this time and at that point was
another key
milestone i have here kind of very
grayed out on this uh
this uh this quote from a strategist
uh the now deceased c.k prahlad who
taught a strategy university of michigan
extensively written
in the harvard business review had a
chance to workshop
the rms strategy before he passed away
and he wrote about
what he called the mature market fallacy
where often
it's not a business that's mature but an
executive's own
conceptualization of the stream of
future opportunities that becomes
mature and sort of challenge yourself to
rethink and reinvent oneself and the
notion of how you can grow and add value
in order to create a future stream of
opportunities for the business
so shortly after the acquisition i sat
down
with uh with the team and with the new
owners
and said you know what i know we think
we can grow this business from 30 odd
million to
40 50 maybe 60 million
uh we know you've put in place a very
generous earn out for us to earn out
our shares and options um and we can see
how this story is going to end like it
does in so many of these situations
the startup team earns out it moves on
and starts up the next business and the
business
uh stays as a interesting niche
analytics firm in our case
30 40 50 million dollars in revenue is
no slouch as a software company
and that's the end of the story and
in this particular case i'm not entirely
sure why
maybe future years of therapy
will help but we sat down and we went to
the new owners and we said you know
we don't think this story is over uh we
don't think
the next chapter is the earn out
and success is a 50 million dollar
version of
rms with some real profits um
how about uh a version of this story
which is
we think we can grow to 100 million
dollars in business
and we had several ideas on how we might
re-envision our opportunities for growth
and how we can monetize that growth and
how about
we essentially kind of restart things up
again so instead of these
very nice earn outs how about we re-up
uh with more equity in the business how
about
a significant new set of grants to
devolve down to recruit
uh the team um re-up the uh the the uh
the veterans who
um were were inclined to uh to uh stick
around for the next phase of growth
and uh let's see if we can actually make
another run at this
uh and not just uh sort of call it
a day at a 30 to 50 million dollar
specialty analytics business
and uh to our great surprise uh the new
parent shareholder said yes so we uh we
re-upped um
a lot of equity was dispersed to the
team we implemented some new ideas
that were about penetrating
more deeply into our customers not just
having them have a license
for our models but really working the
models into the heart of their business
processes
we started to innovate in expanding
beyond natural hazard risk into things
like terrorism risk and disease pandemic
risk
and in many ways the the decade that
followed was the most
productive um and significant growth
stage of the company's
history we went from the beginning of
the decade about 30 million in revenue
to the end of the decade about 250
million of of revenue
we crossed the 100 million dollar
threshold much sooner than we thought
and by the the latter part of uh the
decade
the models had been elevated to a whole
another class of value in our customers
enterprise
and there were and we were really uh had
really reinvigorated
um rms and overcome the the mature
market fallacy
um and reinvented who we are how we add
value and the scale and size
of the opportunities um before us
which then brings us to uh the uh the
present um
you've all heard of this uh uh this this
notion of the
the innovator's dilemma by the
end of last decade 2008 2009
2010 things were looking um pretty good
at rms
um we were we were closing in i think on
250 million in revenue again up from 30
million a decade before
we were quite profitable you know
margins 30
plus percent operating margins we were
growing steadily like a rocket ship but
growing steadily
and we were really woven into the fabric
of the
insurance reinsurance markets that we
serve
and it started to get
a little uncomfortable um and
there was a sense that the language was
starting to change
um the language of meetings in the
company
started going from growth
to how do we protect our market share
the language started shifting from how
are we going to
double the company again as the key
metrics to
how do we ensure we can keep a 50
market share in the business that we're
serving
a lot of language that was
self-congratulatory
it was language that was we are the
leaders
as opposed to we're leading um we are
the most innovative company in the space
as opposed to innovating
and while what we did every day was
quite innovative after all building
stochastic models for
typhoons and floods and terrorism is
inherently
incredibly stimulating and
intellectually demanding work
we were running the same playbook that
we had been running for over a decade
and there was a sense of defending the
status quo
celebrating what we had accomplished as
opposed to re-envisioning how we could
add value
what we needed to do to invest in new
ways of adding value
and how to think of ourselves not as the
market leader
in the field but rather than the 50
percent
market leader in the niche field what's
the market that we could serve that were
the five to ten percent
market share player in and it's the
classic
sort of innovator's dilemma which is how
do you make the shift
from um being so invested in one's own
status quo
to take the necessary risks uh to uh try
to drive a
a new uh round of growth um in the
business
and this was a very interesting and uh
challenging time
the company was not a you know not a
goliath but
by our historic standards we started
five 25 50
you know thousand you know 800 900
people in the business
lots of clients real profits uh
significant revenue streams
market share position we re-envisioned
in a very top-down way a new strategy
for the business
which was one in which would require to
take some very significant risks
in order to pivot um our
fundamental value proposition and how we
add value
in a way when we still had the tools at
our disposal
the uh the financial resources uh
the market position um the uh
the momentum where we could still be in
control
as opposed to settling on increasing
defensive posture about defending market
share
defending position and then waiting for
the time for somebody to change the
rules of the game out from underneath us
after a lot of these kinds of businesses
where you have very significant market
positions
don't often succumb because your number
two or a number three competitor
picks up ten points of market share is
because you become so invested in
defending the status quo
you don't see something coming that
fundamentally change the terms of value
that the customer experiences and the
ways in which they can consume that
value
and there's some disruptive change that
causes you to fundamentally lose the
plot line
and then no matter how much you try to
defend your market share
it's uh it's like sand running through
your hands so we went through this
process which was very challenging
because
we went into our own organization and
said
we need to undergo a substantial pivot
in our strategy we need to go from being
a primarily being seen as the world's
leading
provider of scientifically informed
catastrophe models
to delivering the exposure and risk
management environment
for this industry to yes analyze risk
using models
to manage risk and do so by opening an
ecosystem of capability
to our competitors and to others to
build models and analytics and apple
applications on our platform and deliver
all of that
software and platform as a service in
the cloud
and these conversations were extremely
difficult
internally um some of the most
challenging and the story is not over
yet by the way so i'm not quite sure how
this is all going to
turn out we've had a number
of uh this transformation has been going
on for
over two years now but it started with a
lot of very
angst-filled internal dialogue about why
is there the need for change
and the institutional internal and
cultural barriers to change when you've
been able to
develop a reasonably successful business
that has a well-defined
brand and market position that is
understood by employees and customers
alike
to be doing something very specific very
well
and getting compensated for that to make
the pivot and do something different
only happens in one of two situations uh
one is when you're under existential
threat of death
and that's quite a motivator to try
something different or the opportunities
are so
significant it challenges you to think
differently and take some risks
and we went through a whole internal
process and i made
so many mistakes and learned so many
things the hard way
about how a top-down strategy
uh to take an organization that was
intensely proud as it should be of
everything
you had accomplished over 20 years of
innovation in a very specific dimension
to take that organization through change
and build the case for change
was extremely difficult and we got there
we got there we got full alignment but
it took a lot longer than i thought
it was much harder than i imagined and
it was
very scary at times when you are
starting to
pivot the company and try to bring the
culture with you
and realize that you might fracture the
very organization that brought you to
this place
and you haven't yet made the definitive
not only intellectual case but emotional
case for why a company
should go through significant change
it's a very scary place
as a leader to go through that
realization that you might not
make it to the other side and often it's
not the customers or the market who
votes it's your own employees and
colleagues
who vote whether they buy in uh to the
rationale for change and stick with you
uh through the process we've been going
through this journey now
for almost three years we are we have
been building
uh what we call rms one which is
certainly
uh going to deliver world class
catastrophe models
but is essentially now we're positioning
as an environment for resilient and
real-time exposure and risk management
and we are framing this as a core system
in our clients
enterprise delivered as a cloud based
service and we feel can more than double
our addressable market
we are going to market in about six
weeks
with the initial release of rms one
so this story is not yet over but we
have
made the pivot internally and gotten
significant buying alignment
um and held the company together through
a very significant internal change
management effort uh new priorities and
investments in the business and
technology
and colleagues um if you look at the
senior 20 people in the rms leadership
team right now
7 21 senior 21 people in the rms
leadership team
uh 17 of the 21 are either new or had a
very different job
just two years ago so tremendous amount
of change
in the leadership team but we brought
the core culture through
the modeling team stayed intact are as
enthusiastic as ever about delivering
great models
to this platform but there's just a
whole a lifetime of lessons i feel i've
learned
about the soft part about
leading transformation change in one's
own culture
and many mistakes were made but i think
we learned fast enough
that we're coming through okay on the
other side and now we're delivering
a very significant new platform
several hundred million dollars of
investment have gone into the software
engineering
and cloud computing infrastructure we've
stood up data centers
in iceland in the uk in canada
here in california and soon in asia
and we are we are going to market with a
significant offering as a private cloud
uh not only to offer up our models but
the models of our competitors
and others in what we hope to be as a
specialized risk management ecosystem of
third-party providers
via our platform to this very large
trillion dollar global financial
services industry
that's looking to manage risk now being
modelers
we haven't uh we we are still fiercely
uh aware of our core dna
among other things we did is generate
exceeding probability curves
for the number of cores we would need to
have on demand
to meet the use cases of simultaneous
clients firing off
large-scale hurricane flood and
earthquake analyses all at the same time
and we're modeling here the probability
that in any one day during
peak business season we will need more
than thirty thousand thirty five
thousand
forty fifty thousand so this is
significant big compute
infrastructure that we're building to be
able to scale up
to deliver this much compute capacity in
a cloud
to the needs of an entire vertical
market
and we haven't forgotten that we are
modelers
as i close in on a couple of wrap up
commas i i do want to leave a little
time for q a um
you know what do i know i have only
worked at one job
my whole career lots of different
experiences
in that 25 years but a couple of things
that i
wanted to share maybe as sort of uh
summary thoughts um i guess first off is
uh
there is more to life than social media
technology companies um
you don't have to ride in a big gleaming
white bus to come to work
and if you're interested in big data
analytics you can do something more
socially meaningful than build
algorithms to help people buy more stuff
on the web
there are a lot of companies like rms
harnessing big compute scientific
computing
um and very sophisticated analytic
analytic capabilities to solve
really serious uh mission scale
problems and encourage you as students
to recognize that there are lots of cool
companies
doing very serious stuff with this kind
of uh
this kind of technology um strategic
intent matters um it's okay and i think
at times necessary
to have heroic aspirations as ck prahlad
said
all out of proportion with one's
capabilities
and the challenge isn't not to envision
the gap but how to systematically
challenge your organization
uh to close the gap and that sets up my
third point which is mission matters
rms uh since day one
has been a purpose-driven company our
big ideal
from when we started the company was to
make the world a safer and more
resilient
place and that i don't mean just as a
slogan there's a whole theory of the
firm
which connects what we do to
the markets that we serve to the
problems we are trying to help them
solve to making the world a safer and
more resilient place
both ex post disasters by having more
coverage
to finance the recovery of communities
after disasters
and ex-ante by building in the financial
incentives to create
mitigation to reduce loss when the
events occur
uh mission matters and mission matters
not because it's just
cool and it makes you feel good when you
look at it at
your slogan on the wall but when you
need to go take an organization
through years of change and sometimes
very painful change
when whether it's you know almost 40
turnover
due to exogenous factors in your
business or the pivot to a major
strategic
change which is very risky and how to
hold your organization's culture intact
if you have a strong mission it's not
you know do you have cool slides and you
get great sushi at lunch it's
do you really have a purpose that your
team buys into that transcends the
day-to-day of what you work
that really matters that makes you
believe in your core
that what you do makes an impact if you
believe that if you have that
mission-based ethos and organization
you can be extremely resilient at times
of great change and challenge and risk
and take the organization through that
through that uh journey
um another observation is sometimes
things that matter take time
um it seems like you know i'm not some
i guess i am kind of an old guy coming
back to stanford to talk to a bunch of
students but
uh um you know it seems like so much
focus now is is
around building and flipping and
transacting businesses
where you know yeah there might be a nod
to a mission statement or a big hairy
audacious goal at the end of the day
the organization is started geared wired
and
run to affect the the takeout the sale
the acquisition or the or the liquidity
event and
things that matter and there's a lot of
things in the world that need to be
sorted out the really big things that
matter sometimes take time now maybe you
don't just stick around in the same
business like i have for 25 years and
to make a go of it but i think we need
to extend our half-life to solve the
kind of problems
requires a commensurate cognitive scale
of thought purpose and action
that can't be solved in a three-year
cycle and then on to the next thing
sometimes you think take time and i know
it's hard
uh to think in gen decadal terms but i
fully expect to be here in 25 years
still in pursuit
of this of this heroic mission and
finally um take the time
uh to invest in your own learning and
development
and grow as a person i know that can
sound kind of
soft and woolly coming from an engineer
speaking to many engineers but i think a
lot of people now confuse
developing oneself with networking
right right you guys all do that
yourself networking
yes of course there's opportunities to
create to learn that's not what i'm
talking about
it's about having the humility
to recognize how little you know and
how important it is to continually and
passionately invest in your own
self-discovery to make yourself a more
effective leader one of the best
opportunities i had
a tremendous opportunity that took full
advantage of is that i got invited to
participate in a leadership development
program put on by the aspen
institute and unfortunately it wasn't
two years of full time in aspen
colorado but it was a three year elapsed
time where
i got the chance to spend many weeks
in a program intense program with some
wonderful people
in the spirit of community-based
leadership
ethical leadership and leadership with
purpose and it's these kinds of things
that
you know often get overlooked in the
frenzy of the next big thing and the
next flip and the next valuation round
and the next startup
and find time uh to uh to pursue
uh one's own growth and finally i'd like
to just say
my own management team is very excited
i'm here
um out of this 20-odd person leadership
team we have today
almost half of the the team about 40 are
stanford alums
um either in the business school or the
engineering schools
uh so we feel very uh proud to be part
of this community
and thrilled to have this opportunity
and this honor to uh to come share out
our experiences
uh with you uh what we've gone through
over the last 25 years
so with that i just want to thank you
for this opportunity i think we've got
exactly you know seven minutes four
questions and rich you can't ask me any
hard questions yeah
yeah yes so what are the biggest lessons
you learned in
in your latest business strategy shift
in changing the dna of the company
getting everyone to move around to the
new direction well i think the
uh there's a lot there's a lot i think
getting people the first mistake i made
was overly intellectualizing the
strategy
of course it makes sense it's so evident
here's the logical argument
and didn't engage people enough
emotionally and
why there was a need for change and
engage
people as human beings emotionally
around why should they as people
buy into a new strategy um and why
that strategy doesn't alienate them from
the business that they love
and they made the choice to come work
here and uh
that was uh something that i um i feel
like uh
if if if i do this again i will spend
far more time on
on that aspect getting emotional buy-in
uh from the team as opposed to just
trying to cram it down
top down because it makes uh
intellectual sense another thing that um
was you know maybe it's an unfortunate
statement on on human nature but
in the early days of the change
management process which i guess is the
uh
the proper way to refer to these things
it didn't seem like much like a process
at the time but
initially the change management process
i spent a lot i'm a very
uh a very optimistic person i'm a glass
half
full person and i sold the need for
change
in very aspirational this is a huge
opportunity
i find found that also when i when we
realized as a leadership team
that we needed to balance the need for
change with it's going to be great if we
pull this off and the opportunities are
much more
but also that the status quo is not
risk-free so human beings we always
think the status quo
ex-ante is the risk-free option and
change is risky
it's very hard for us i think a lot of
social scientists suggested to
cognitively
realize that the status quo carries a
lot of risk
so we started talking about the downside
and the risks that
things that can go terribly wrong if we
just keep sticking to our knitting
and we didn't overdo that because again
i'm a very optimistic person
but we started dealing in maybe a 22
percent weight on the downside as
opposed to
that really tipped people's minds that
there's a there's a need
where the status quo isn't tenable we
have to change
and the risk of change is balanced
against the risk of not changing
as opposed to just the great stuff
that's going to happen if we
successfully pulled it off
balance against the fear that if we uh
we fail
we're going to squat you know we're
going to have we're going to we're going
to screw up what we already built
so that was uh yes when you say
your addressable market is doubled
so what is that addressable market now
and it
doesn't also include things like
financial market risks
that ms ci bars yeah
all other kinds of restaurants
yeah the uh the the short answer is that
the addressable market
um the way we're defining it is in the
near term we think we double the
business
um the uh the longer term it's the three
vectors volume space um it's about uh
extending um into new classes of risk so
we've got r
d teams working on that kind of thing uh
the second is uh the pivot from
the the value is primarily built around
the it's not just the model it's the
environment and the platform in which
these institutions manage risk including
consuming the tools analytics and
applications of others
and the third is the customer's customer
and the customer's customer's customer a
key part about the cloud proposition
isn't just about doing things more
efficiently is we can now
we have a few hundred customers are
institutional uh what about a few
thousand customers or ten thousand
customers
the broader community of interest that
is exposed to catastrophic risk not just
large insurance companies and hedge
funds
but uh corporations and entities around
the world that we can extend the tale of
the uh the business significantly
yes um so like i know you started off 25
years ago so how do you keep that
innovative
i mean from the leadership perspective
how do you keep that innovative culture
throughout those 25 years and what i
mean like what type of strategies what
type of incentives do you use to
motivate
your employees i think um
i think a lot of it is uh you know
what the psychological damage i got as a
kid i suppose but i mean
there is a kind of there is i mean we
all know this i mean you everybody in
this room is super ambitious
and uh high achieving there there's
there's some
unquantifiable thing that gets you
motivated
to do that and that's with you your
whole life i think um the thing the
more practical uh uh response is
the uh this notion of mission really
matters i mean if you
really internalize why you exist and
what your really big aspiration
you know not just i want to change the
world but watch the theory
that creates a very very big context
and a very distant horizon that stays
evergreen
and constantly creates this tension or
where that when you look at where you
are
you you you're forced to not just look
backwards and think about how far you've
come
how little progress you've made against
your goal and it's that kind of
creative tension that gets created like
oh we have
so much still to do that stimulates this
kind of
innovation and risk-taking
that then gets worked into the culture
of the company
um because you're always you know you're
you're you're stretching yourself so far
in terms of this notion of
what you want to accomplish as a
business yes
so when is the right time to start your
own company
well i think all i can speak about is my
my own experience 22 years old business
plan was written
in school i got to work with
great people like rich and learned from
people like tom
on the job other people might have the
opportunity to go work someplace first
to learn the skills that i learned from
tom
on the job uh there's no right answer
all my own experiences was 22 years old
and
june of 1989 we incorporated
um and we're uh we're pulling
all-nighters
um answering clients questions
yes um i trust you're familiar with like
nassim's top
yeah i love uh anti-fragile concept i'm
just
curious you know how um how you kind of
apply that to
your clients you know i'm not only
telling them where the risks are but how
they can
you know flip risk and sort of jiu-jitsu
on its head and benefit from unexpected
events
yeah we have this uh concept um
it's not a new concept that we look to
to quantify and articulate the
resiliency of our clients risk
management strategies
and it's an inversion of the proposition
so much of
our society and business cultures focus
around optimization
you make a set of assumptions and then
you drive to optimize the hell out of
that system
to maximize the economic returns
and that leads to hyper-efficient supply
chains
that blow up when anything goes wrong
because there's no inventory
in the in the system anymore give you
but one example the same thing happens
with financial services risk
you can have a view of the world that's
that is taken and you
optimize the hell out of the risk
management strategy to maximize
the return on allocated shareholders
capital but what if your assumptions are
wrong
you know we also what happened in
2007-2008
and we've had a couple of versions of
that ourselves we learned the hard way
where clients overly optimized around
our models
and then we're surprised when we learn
the hard way that all models are wrong
and some are useful
um so we have a whole construct now we
use as resiliency where we
explore the fragility of the clients
risk management strategies
to the underlying assumptions to see how
brittle the strategies are we invert the
proposition to provide
a measure of resiliency that they can
use to trade off against the efficiency
optimality imperative
to create a balance between those two
those two competing
criteria for for building a portfolio